k42 here it's not easy being in charge
you have to make all the big decisions
like what's best for everyone how to
improve things and who gets the last bit
of cake in the modern world
we the people generally get some kind of
saying who makes those decisions well
most of the time at least in the past
however you would generally stuck with
royal lineage or whatever lead it had
just murdered the previous boss
I was now using their head as a
footstool sometimes leaders took this
responsibility well and tried to be
Justin fair but pretty often they jumped
headfirst into the crazy pool and never
bothered coming up for air today we look
at some of the most psychopathic
murderous and downright bananas rulers
of the ancient world if you've never
heard of Ivan the Terrible his name is a
pretty hefty clue that he wasn't exactly
the most agreeable of guys Ivan the
fourth was the Russian czar from 15 47
to 15 84 when he died from a stroke
whilst playing chess too dangerous game
kids you've been warned Ivan was a
leader of swords from a very young age
following his father as grand prince of
Muscovy in 1533 a historical area around
moscow this was at the tender age of 3
when his Papa died of a leg infection
his mother went soon afterwards when he
was 8 but this was a suspected poisoning
when Ivan was 16 he crowned himself Tsar
of all of Russia which at this point was
a series of territories run by different
rulers despite being a devout Christian
Ivan was a little unstable
probably not helped by all a leg and
poison related deaths of his parents and
his first wife as a youngster he was
said to have entertained himself by
tossing puppies off of balconies so he
was basically the 16th century version
of Justin Bieber and as he expanded his
kingdom taking on the Turks the Kazan
the Crimean Tatars and many others
he enjoyed dealing out a good punishment
he would wall up entire cities so his
troops could bring a good 500 to a
thousand prisoners out every day and
impale them or actually cook them to
death in giant frying pans
since he was a family man he'd bring his
son along to watch but eventually he
killed him too when he beat him round
the head with a pointed staff during a
family feud makes your Christmas dinner
argument seem a little better now
doesn't it
tamerlane the great sounds a little
friendlier but he was one of the world's
biggest mass murderers Mao Zedong may
have overseen up to 75 million deaths
but Tama lanes 15 to 20 million is
staggering considering there were only
350 million people on earth at that
point he wiped out 5% of the entire
global population and that's what how
bombs or guns he freely got to upload
the hard work and dedication he must
have put in tamerlane also known as
timur founded the timurid empire at the
end of the 14th century and claimed to
be descended from Genghis Khan who came
about two hundred years before and he
was also pretty handy at the genocide
game we've all got to have heroes right
Karns Mongol Empire covered a much
larger area than Tama lanes and his
armies afford to have slaughtered almost
60 million Tamerlane declared himself
the sword of Islam and tried to rebuild
the mongol empire under his religion but
he wasn't exactly at his most saintly
when he had 90,000 people in baghdad
beheaded or when he forced people to die
of slow suffocation he also had great
towers built from his enemies schools so
he was pretty good at recycling too Vlad
the Impaler also has one of those
delightfully informative names Vlad was
part of the house of Dracula ste and
ruled Transylvania in the 15th century
if this all sounds a little familiar
it's because it's the inspiration for
Bram Stoker's novel Dracula Vlad set
about protecting his people and
Christianity from the surrounding
Ottoman forces and did a pretty good job
of it he built a fearsome reputation
largely thanks to his hobby of you
guessed it impaling people he once put
all 20,000 men women and children of the
city of amla's on spiked sticks through
their bodies and faces ouch but I don't
want you to think he was a one-trick
pony
he also skinned boiled decapitated
blinded strangled hand
roasted hacked nailed and buried alive
which sounds like the menu it's some
kind of hipster pop-up restaurant I'll
have to a strangled rabbit with buried
aubergine please move aside a forced
ruble and for dessert Vlad's own head
would fit the bill as it said he was
decapitated by the Turks and it was sent
to Constantinople in a jar of honey the
Roman Empire had a pretty good run of
crazy rulers so it's hard to pick a
worse one what today we're going for
Caligula thanks to quote such as I wish
Rome had bought one neck so that I could
cut off all our heads with one blow he
was a third emperor of Rome from 1837 to
AD 41 and got the nickname Caligula
meaning little boots from his time as a
boy when he accompanied his father the
general Germanicus to various battles he
took over Rome from Tiberius and its own
clearweather he assassinated his
predecessor or not but it wouldn't be
that unlikely he then proceeded to spend
just under four years turning the palace
into a giant brothel and having anyone
around him put to death if he was angry
or bored or just had a few minutes to
spare he was eventually assassinated by
conspirators he wanted to restore the
Roman Republic what this failed and then
offer Emperor was installed instead if
you're going to come up with a secret
plan to overturn the Roman government
then have a follow up plan at least
what would the people's front of Judea
think aside from his notorious cruelty
and obsession with rather suspicious
hanky-panky he also appointed his
favorite horse in potatoes as an
official priest not the most stable
decision not to be outdone by all of the
men we have a female tyrant on the list
as well empress wu ruled China from 690
to 705 and is the only woman in Chinese
history to have power in her own right
and she made sure she wouldn't be
forgotten as she was a ruthless and
psychotic leader who drove her people
into misery she was renowned for
ordering daily tortures and forced
suicides as well as her sexual depravity
we started out life in court as a
concubine for Emperor Taizong
and
somehow managed to escape her expected
retirement have going to the Nanami
after the Emperor died instead even
though it was frowned upon she became a
concubine for his son emperor gaozong
she then worked her way up to empress by
some pretty brutal means including
strangling her own daughter to death in
order to frame the Emperor's wife some
people will stop at nothing for a bigger
bedroom and an ensuite soon we was
installed as a new Empress and was
making most of the decisions when her
husband died her son was made Emperor
but she soon had him exiled for not
doing what she wanted and eventually
defied tradition to take complete power
herself the Byzantine Empire was a
continuation of the Roman Empire in the
East centred in Istanbul then called
Constantinople from 1976 to 10:25 it was
ruled by Basel a second who also had one
of those popular the based names Basel
the bulgar Slayer and the bull cos were
Bulgarians not that weird type of wheat
that you're strange vegan friends are
obsessed with Basel really didn't like
Bulgarians for some peculiar reason and
he had numerous wars with them one of
which lasted over 30 years he was
finally victorious in the Battle of
Clyde on and had a rather over-the-top
punishment for his 15,000 prisoners his
army used red-hot pokers and daggers to
blind all 15,000 of them but left every
hundred-person
with one eye so that they could lead the
rest home because he didn't want them
all milling about causing queues for the
showers and stuff apparently the
Bulgarian ruler died of a stroke when he
saw what had been done to his people
bustle on the other hand was thoroughly
pleased with himself and repeated a
trick again in Macedonia two years later
a good jokes a good joke I guess and
finally a popular favorite and tailored
the hood also known as until a
discourage of God until his empire grew
in the middle of the fifth century and
stretched all the way from Germany into
Russia he set out to destroy the Roman
Empire and just generally anyone who
disagreed with him his nickname scourge
of God was due to the fact that he was
so damn awful
everyone thought that he must be some
kind of holy punishment much like how
the modern world feels about Piers
Morgan he once met st. Ursula a holy
virgin and asked to marry her she turned
him down and in a fit of rage he had her
killed along with 11,000 of her
companions it's even thought that he
could have drunk some of the woman's
blood so although the current political
climate is pretty heated I suppose it's
good to know that things could be worse
but then again just like your CV I'm
sure some things have been exaggerated
over time and who knows what stories
will be written in the future about
Donald Trump Vladimir the shirtless and
Boris the total Johnson thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2 it's
estimated that every year in Japan
hundreds of people are wrongfully
convicted for crimes they didn't commit
this tower of testosterone is Danish man
beast Peter Freudian he is the most
interesting man in the world